microstrategy the very first company to
put bitcoin on their balance sheet
revealed on friday that they are going
to raise up to 500 million dollars
through a stock sale and many people
believe that they're gonna go and buy
more bitcoin now this comes after
microstrategy and michael saylor have
spent approximately two billion dollars
to purchase 130 000 bitcoin or so
they've done this by doing stock sales
and raising an enormous amount of debt
now as they've done it their balance
sheet has swelled and the stock price
took off towards the moon in recent
months as the entire tech sector got
crushed microstrategy stock wasn't safe
either
but that doesn't change the fact that
microstrategy has nearly 130 000 bitcoin
sitting on their balance sheet as we saw
michael saylor the founder of
microstrategy also decided to step down
as ceo and step up as the executive
chairman
his focus now is on the bitcoin strategy
they have a new ceo stepping in and he
will run their software business
it appears that as michael saylor has
stepped into that executive chairman
role he is not going to slow down 500
million dollars from a stock sale to buy
more bitcoin at a price close to 20 000
it's a hell of a lot of bitcoin now
what's interesting about this is that
michael saylor has talked over and over
and over again about a deep commitment
to this bitcoin strategy regardless of
if the price is high
low or anywhere in between that means
that sometimes he'll buy bitcoin at
cheap prices and other times he'll buy
the quote-unquote bitcoin top but that's
all okay if you have a long-term belief
in an asset and you're willing to
continue to just dollar cost average
into it no different than warren buffett
and charlie munger saying we look for
great assets and we simply want to hold
them forever
michael saylor is deeply committed to
bitcoin and this most recent 500 million
dollar stock sale is going to prove that
he still believes in acquiring as much
bitcoin as possible
microstrategy has a gigantic bet on the
digital currency and my guess is that
this will go down as one of the greatest
business strategy moves in the last
couple of decades
michael saylor is trying to transform a
software business into the leading
company in a sector that continues to
grow at an insane pace a lot of times
you simply have to pick the right market
get ahead of the trend and then simply
be disciplined and patient that appears
to be exactly what microstrategy is
doing right now hey you did you like
this video great make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time